United 367 preparing for takeoff please
advise
copy that 367 standby
[Music]
you are one of the brightest students I
have ever had and you are failing my
class do you hear about this flight
operations were temporarily suspended
this afternoon after reports of
mysterious aircraft hovering about the
airport I'm gonna need the footage from
this entire facility I want all those
passengers in conference room a no way
it's way bigger when I was a kid I saw
something
these lights outside of it wasn't a
drone the guy on TV was like you don't
automatically jump to the most extreme
explanation this isn't some textbook
problems it's more complicated than
anything you've ever seen before this
terminal is crawling with federal agents
why would they still be here if they
figured out what it was we need to shut
him down
FBI is monitoring our computers why
didn't I see this before
think of some sort of signal that's
binary they're using math is a way to
communicate and if I'm right it's coming
back
there's an opportunity to take a giant
leap forward everything is riding on it
what are the most important questions in
the world is there a god what happens
when we die
are we alone in the universe if anyone
answered any one of those questions it
would change everything
[Music]
you
you